Guess who just turned up at my place.
It is Grant Thompson The King Of Random
G: What's up guys
D: Grant is actually going to show me a little survival tip,
let's say you're stuck out in the woods, and you need to make a fire, but you don't have say... Matches or a lighter
We're going to try to use a ziploc bag to start a fire
G: I guess when you're building a fire the first thing you're going to need is some tinder
So we're gonna have to go scavenge around for some options this stuff works pretty well
D: now this is pretty dry
G: Yeah, we definitely want something that's off the ground if possible because we need it as dry as possible
The first step was to grind up the tinder into a fine powder. I'm just following Grant's instructions here
I'm not really sure if this is going to work see that right there. That's the stuff We're going for it's super fine
We're gonna take our base plate. We're going to pinch a nice little pile in there. okay, so at this point We're pretty much ready
to start
the ignition process
So what do we need for that? ...for that We're going to need Ziplock bag and a little bit of water
Now this is just a regular ziploc sandwich Baggie. We're going to pour that in till it's about halfway full, you let me know when
Grab water from a Creek or stream or wherever you like now
Here's the trick we want to develop this into some kind [of] a liquid sphere
We're going to be making a liquid magnifying glass
I do that by turning my ziploc bag you know 45 degrees
So it creates this diamond shape and then we're [just] going to gather these two Corners together
We're going to lose a little bit of water as we do okay
I'm going to pinch that off and the next goal is to twist it trap all that water inside
You see as I twist it it creates pressure that exerts [-] almost an equal pressure on all sides
And now while it's not a perfect sphere
It will eventually start to bubble out
Into a nice liquid sphere where we need it we've essentially just made a makeshift magnifying glass
And you start to fire the same way you would with a magnifying glass
Now once he rolled the ball around you can see where it looks the best
We're looking for as close to as sphere as possible. Which is right there now if I back it out
[wow]
You can see there start smoking immediately that's incredible the focal length of the lens is the place where [all] of the light converges?
That's really what we're trying to establish here, right is
Position the tinder pile at the focal point of this
Spherical by convex lens [essentially] now you can see [that's] been smoking [for] a little while Mm-hmm
We've developed a little bit of an Ember base. It's burned a little bit
Yeah, so now I'm going to sprinkle a little bit more fuel on top there
And that will cause the heat to rise and burn that from the bottom and I'm going to again from the top nice
It's interesting how you're like kind of bringing it down so that the surface of that is not actually where the most concentrated
Rays are you're concentrating even deeper down into the pile. That's right because
We don't want the heat to [dissipate] too much, and if we're at an extreme focal point like this. Yes
The heats going to bleed off, so if we can warm the surrounding area it actually helps speed the process, right?
We're just going to repeat that process until it will stay smoking on its own
[we've] only been at this for a minute or two and the amount of smoke
We're seeing there is it's pretty significant [a] little bit of sprinkle a little bit of sunlight rinse and repeat. We're really elevating the temperature
Mm-Hmm I
Just point our pile smoking pretty well on its own now
I'm going to go ahead and take this plastic bag and just set it to the side we could reuse this again if we wanted
To at this point. We can probably start adding smaller pieces of tinder. You'll get a few of these little pieces here
We're going to go down to small we want it to be extremely light airy
Sure to still allow the [oxygen] to get in there exactly because if you take away the oxygen you smother the fire cool
I think right there. We're just going to let it sit for a [couple] minutes now
Well that's going we can start chopping up some of these pieces. We just found lying on the ground. They're dry
It's almost like straw. We're going to pull them into very thin fibers
We want to make something that [resembles] a bird's nest something that's light airy and can catch fire very quickly now
We need to transfer this without disturbing the coals as much as possible
The way that I like to do that is take this base. Mm-hmm. We're going to take this grass
We're going to put over top and we're just going to gently roll. It over like this
[oh] wow now you can see all those hot coals transfer down into the grass and we're just going to cover it over
To help conceal block it from some of the wind
like this and
now because of all that straw the air can flow through it and help build the heat one trick that I use it look a
Little bit funny, I just stick this in my hand and spin in circles
[see]
And it really works honestly
That's impressive
You can already see it smoking a little bit more
We're going to give that a second just for the heat to build back up
Yeah
but you can totally see
There's a lot more fuel catching on fire now what we want to be seeing is thicker smoke and we want to see it
progressing so we see the smoke dying down or getting weaker like slow down get out of the breeze give it a chance for the
Heat to build this is ready if you look down in there. You can almost see glowing Red Embers now
It wants to light it wants to light it
Just needs a little bit of a flick it's going to build up a little more a little spinning trick
[oh] you see that goes hot flame. I'll go amazing boom and then we're out here. Oh
Ha ha shoot. Sorry [Derrick] is [ok]
We've clearly demonstrated forming fire. Well that my friend is how to start a fire [with] a sandwich bag and bright side
[eh] [that's] nicely done. [I] want to say a huge. Thank you to grant here king of random
You should go check out his channel. There's lots of very random things and it's taught me a thing or two
That's for sure [a] lot about survival
Hacks and a lot of those things that you really shouldn't try at home
And then we show you why you shouldn't try them at home back?
We just put a video on my channel trying to melt glass we took a Dr.
Pepper bottle and melted that in the back here, and I worked amazingly well, so go check it out
I'll put a link in the description
(www.youtube.com/c/MinhtanVietsub)